tu veux un café
non
à un général quand il dit qu'il veut pas
quelque chose c'est qu'ils en crèvent
dans vie quinze ans de pratique
thébaux ça va s'arranger
c'est moi qui suis allé la chercher
je refuse d'être une femme pleurnicharde
tu l'as dans la pompe utah dans la peau
je peux pas vous en vouloir pour ça
surtout j'y peux rien je m'en fous donc
virginie et moi avons décidé de prendre
garde alternée une semaine sur deux
mieux comme ça un nom j'adore ta famille
vous vous êtes extra je comprends que ce
soit difficile voire impossible de
quitter une femme comme vous
il va y revenir à revenir sur son
orgueil en a pris un coup sa fierté
mais il va revenir bien
et voici ma chérie c'est ridicule au
divorce pas toxique le projet d'école
qui touche le plaçant plutôt bien de
toute façon de couper surpoids sont
confrontés ou moins une fois dans leur
vie à l'adultère comme ça pour moi c'est
fait et encore je pense que le troisième
coupe ne dit pas totalement la vérité
d'une passe le sceqe atteint merci
fouiller dans les portables mais quelle
drôle d'idée tu as eu de vol en
souffrance maintenant fermé les yeux
c'est beaucoup plus simple que les avons
nous pas des trous c'est bon tu fais
comment je fais comment je fais remplir
le même devoir conjugal tous les soirs
merci bien tout plaide a toujours eu des
gros besoins ça bouge très vite fatigué
mais c'est dans mes bras qu il dans le
soir il est toujours rentré et à jamais
des couches et tolérance c'est ça le
secret quand on parle du loup
maintenant qu'il est à la retraite il
fait ça dans le quartier je crois qu'il
a une liaison avec une pharmacienne
pesticides et est quelqu'un est mort non
mais non jean une liaison depuis un an
sandrine s'en est aperçu elle lui a
demandé de choisir il a quitté ma fille
c'est bien c'est fait part j'ai cru
qu'il est arrivé quelque chose de grave
je m'appuie les petits bouts le ferait
plaisir de les voir
bon on m'excuser je vais prendre une
douche comme cinq minutes
c'est même la maison qui la font sentir
le cerveau les autres merci bien
bonjour je n'étais pas en soi
en revanche demain je démissionne oui tu
me l'a déjà dit chercher un titre en
particulier je vais en prendre deux j'en
connais pas ce qu'est l'auteur voulait
proposer de prendre mon mari une semaine
sur deux bien sûr jenny et moi avons
décidé de prendre garde alternée
il va y revenir au début je crois avec
la moitié mais là tu vois les choses
évoluent gentiment par abba nouvelle
copine trafic bien
semaine recto et moins ne pas y aller
chez la dame
c'est important que vous connaissiez
davantage la maîtresse de votre poids je
demande à quoi tu croyais que j'allais
te laisser de taper mon mari pendant que
masterchef les gosses c'est un pays de
départ je languis de retrouver ta
baguette magique
j'ai dit il et c'est sa femme qui pousse
plus avec et moi tu peux pas juste me
dire je couche avec ma femme
bah c'est ma femme
non non
ce soir je t'attends à 18 heures
puisqu'on peut passer une semaine sans
qu'on tienne un nom à a
raconte moi bien mon petit bonhomme tu
partirais ton pantalon et un terrain
baiser pas plus tard qu immédiatement
merci chérie je suis vraiment crevé
damon et ben non merci dit-il pas non
merci
soit pas poli s'il te plaît n'y a rien
de pire